[Music]
how are you life is good man thank you
so much for your email I have a lot of
empathy what it takes to send an email
like that and so I appreciate the
feedback yeah you know I think me and
you kind of have a good relationship
from you know send me back to Aria
through the years and yeah you know your
honest guy and meet you and yep and you
know yeah let me give you my take on it
and then why don't you fire away with
some questions based on the feedback I'm
about to give you a cool yeah yeah so
you know in that podcast that I gave
contextually the way I framed it I don't
know you know obviously there was clips
and I don't know how many people watch
the whole podcast or listen to the whole
podcast or what what context I could
have created that was better or building
on me talking about this at agent 2021
in other places it is it is deeply my
opinion that if that the amount that far
too many people in her 20s and 30s
maximize their down payment on a home
right leaving them with no liquid to be
able to do things with them and if they
are like me like I said I write and are
entrepreneurial and on the offense that
there are better uses of their dollars
than buying a home because in renting a
home or an apartment they would take
that to hit you know you know
theoretically that to 300,000 that
they're putting down on a downpayment
and they're putting it to work whether
in their business building their brand
through their ads or investing in the
stock market right so that's that's my
point of view obviously in lieu of the
way you wrote the email a couple things
number one agent 2021 first of all I
think probably the most important part
of this brother is I don't think that my
opinion is a covering most people be
it's not necessarily right it's my
hypothesis of where the world's going
not how the world acted in the past
right number two number two I'm in
advertising I have a 200 million dollar
advertising
company and every single piece of
content that I put out that you see
99.9% of my customers do not agree with
me on I'm definitely just so you know
I'm definitely not one of those people
obviously you know I follow you I watch
you we've interacted but what yep I
believe in a lot of the [ __ ] you say and
to be honest I think that you're right
as far as if you're an entrepreneur yep
in your twenties or thirties
yep that there is you could live at home
and and they were mom and dad and in
back yeah or or by the way or by mine
but my point is I think there's gonna be
an interesting emerging opportunity for
people to rent homes versus buying them
right now I mean I live in Miami yeah
and the ground up development that
didn't let me change I mean it no it is
what it is it's the time I think I think
in hindsight a the the big miss was the
way the way it was positioned by me you
know the way we positioned it as a micro
clip not having full context that's on
me right like this is where every T&I
has to be crossed in my environment
these days because if I'm not
contextualizing then it becomes a mass
thing I mean to be frank this point of
view that Chris took that you're saying
in the email that like why would I take
people's money at a conference that I
don't believe I don't believe that my a
personal opinion on home buying to a
small subset of America has anything to
do with what I should bring in value to
an audience at an event in a ticket
price form right you know that to me
there's literally no connection I have
empathy look here's what the this
thought and I've read all the feedback
from all the real estate agents on
private forums using my accounts to back
chatter this thought that I'm
endangering people's livelihood is the
single is the single greatest compliment
of my career I mean you know all right
that's laughable like like like I don't
have point zero zero zero zero zero
zero zero zero one percent influence on
the masses on their home buying strategy
and and and so I think you definitely
have a great influence on people I think
people take your opinion I mean it is
definitely not a cult kind of guy but
people definitely take their opinion and
use it the one thing I want to please
please know you said you said two
hundred thousand I think that you know
I'm not harping on that but that doesn't
account for that accounts for New York
City and Miami and the big market but
not across America you're right no so so
by the way well I like by the way look
to me this is about a psychology and I
was speaking about me right so if you're
Sally in rural Iowa and you're putting
down twenty thousand right on a hundred
thousand dollar home and you've got my
psychology I'm fascinated based on them
back to your point it doesn't have to be
that big of a downpayment when the down
payments are smaller the multipliers are
smaller too
so her hundred thousand dollar home ten
years later I'm fascinated by what
happens if she pays rent instead and has
that sixteen thousand to go to work
that's all yes obviously yeah based on
the market yeah you know New York City
obviously the prices you know real
estate is yep spent this [ __ ] on the
commercial side yep never shown a real
downturn except for 2008 I mean yep yep
you know in the same sense and I just
didn't understand and obviously you have
to because you're so big and an
advertiser that the things that you say
might be taken out of context and by the
way you'll appreciate this you'll
appreciate this I don't think we did a
good enough job that was so what really
this is actually a change that I've made
on my team the clip I'm fine with
because my team's clipping and we're
clipping we we need to be a little bit
more thoughtful we've got two incidents
recently where I'm saying one thing at
one point and then I'm wrapping my
thoughts 17 minutes later and we have to
be thoughtful on top of which I post
everything on every platform except
my daily podcast on Instagram where they
take a clip and they post it what we've
been doing that I think really put me in
a vulnerable spot was they are naming
that meme and they're hyperbolized I'm
looking at Jason right now he sent me a
clip yesterday where he said drug
dealers are the best entrepreneurs he
has this great clip where I don't
believe that but I believe drug dealers
have entrepreneurial tendencies that is
a massive difference I believe that a
lot of entrepreneurial on the offense 20
to 35 year olds should not put down
payments on homes use that capital to
build wealth and then buy their home at
39 42 44 because I have a funny feeling
that home will look different and won't
take them out of the game of opportunity
but the way we clipped it was and the
way they titled it is and I don't even
remember but I think it's something the
degree of do you know it no one I don't
want to buy a home well it's not bad
instead of nonetheless it could have
easily said no one should ever buy a
home right because the team is
copywriting and doing all these things
so let me say this because this is real
life I'm the reason it was taken out of
context I do not believe that the
industry took me out of context and and
for that I have to deal with the
ramifications that I'm dealing with
right now I'm not in the business I
don't have eight minutes for my family
or my top executives I'm on the phone
with you right now I don't real quick I
don't say that to like for you to
appreciate it I'm saying that I'm
willing to pay the piper when I know
that I didn't put myself in the best
position what did it right so i titled i
titled the clip I got no wasn't there's
a separate one on Twitter the one that
everybody got upset about is not the one
that's titled on your team account is I
I'm pissed I bought a home the Twitter
one has a different title uh-huh and
more importantly more here's the biggest
punchline
I have no problem with being
historically incorrect that
entrepreneurs should not put their money
to use and should put down it on a home
because the home market explodes over
the next 30 years my biggest problem is
that
people viewed it as me trying to attack
their livelihood and somehow ripping
them off by throwing a conference do you
know what I mean you know I didn't think
that at all I was just confused and I
just I'm a speck on I just think it was
bad timing I just think that like you
know everybody was pumped up about age
of twenty twenty-one course if a brother
brother did you listen to Mikey no like
I dressed I it in the keynote that I
don't think it's a good use of people's
capital right that's right so what what
you know what I had the luxury of
contextualizing it so what's really
interesting is and and others are using
it for what they need to use it for
right obviously everything is take it
can be and by the way by the way by the
way by the way it is the clip is
literally titled I'm pissed I own a home
yeah so but I mean I think I think
that's important because the
manipulation of it for other people's
agenda for awareness or whatever they're
trying to push is something that has to
be taken into account that being said if
I believe that that's what happened I
would never be on this call with you I
believe that we clipped in a way and to
be honest with you because I'm gonna go
listen to the podcast this weekend I'm
not sure if I did a good enough job
clarifying it in the entire 45 minutes
the way I'm doing it now in circumstance
circumstance we're on where I'm
historically able to put myself in a
peculiar spot is when I'm hyped onstage
or an interview and I make an absolute
statement and don't add the little
writing in the bottom and I have to
understand that when those moments
happen and boy am I trying to be better
at it that I deserve to deal with the
ramifications and and and you know I
mean look the craziest by mean there's
so much going on I mean we're we're
moving our events business from Vayner
to pure Wow and 137 like like I've got
so many different things going on like
do you know what the funniest part is I
pretty much like can't believe that like
I
I have so much empathy for anybody who's
upset or disappointed with me that all I
want to do is be honest many 11 minute
and 16 seconds calls as I can I'm not
gonna be able to get all the way there
but I do really appreciate a tone and a
tenor of your email but I will but I
will say like in your email where it
says like hey taking advantage of people
for the ticket and things that nature I
genuinely don't believe that's your
feelings like that's why I'm calling you
it was in it was it was in it was in
almost like almost rhetoric on on why
would you do this because this is not
what you do right yeah you you listen
your emails like I I couldn't believe in
us more I guess is the best thing I can
say i-i-i-i I'm also fascinated by the
ability for people to take an opinion
that is a real opinion you know there
was people that said I did it for
controversy I was like you know what
those people are just trying to make a
point and they're angry or they're
frustrated or whatever they don't really
know those are the people that are on
the outside and don't really know that
you don't do this [ __ ] for that but
there's a there's a really interesting
part right like Mike as you probably
know cuz now it's out there quite a bit
my sister's a real estate agent yeah you
know it was funny like I was talking to
her and this is now kind of nothing this
is blown over but obviously four days
ago this was much more white heat than
it is today so just talking to normal
life I guess is not on this issue and
then it got brought up again yesterday
and I said to her I'm like sis I really
believe in this like you should really
become educated on what high net-worth
or like people that actually do have
money what kind of homes they want to
rent like like I don't think I don't I'm
not saying this I I believe it I believe
that there will be a lot of 2520 the
amount of people who in America normally
would buy a home at 28 who instead are
gonna buy a first home at 39
that's four times the value in size of
the home they would have bought a 28 is
gonna be far greater I really genuinely
believe that and I'm not saying that to
hurt people's feelings or or put their
livelihoods in it's because I believe it
as a truth and I don't view real estate
agents viewing me attacking their
livelihood I view it as if you
thoughtfully process it in your head and
if you disagree with me then you move on
but if you think there's something to it
maybe you add to your business
capabilities right you know I'm a prime
example real quick so I decided after I
sold my last house to rent and invest in
a beverage company and crushing it right
now but what is that that's my personal
opinion my business opinion is that if
it's done the right way home ownership
will always be a great investment yes
but - but but this is not a debate if
it's a great investment it's a debate of
instead of looking backwards of how it's
been over the last 70 years taking into
account what what the 20 year olds of
America are thinking today absolutely I
mean and by the way by the way by the
way and you know and I think you need to
ask yourself in the mirror if that's
what you've done is your business advice
predicated on what's in your best
financial vested interest because one of
the things that I will tell you that I'm
most proud of is when I [ __ ] on
television commercials and programmatic
banner ads I'm losing tons of money if
people were thoughtful truly thoughtful
and non-emotional about what I did they
would understand the level of
transparency I I did not consider nor
will I ever consider the timing of agent
2021 or anything else because when I
sell something I say to myself if
somebody's gonna buy this bottle of wine
sneaker ticket to a conference or hire
vaynermedia are they getting the value
that they're paying for for that that's
how I think about it but I'm speaking my
truth not what makes me the most money
no I get that and that's why that's why
what I put in the email is very because
I know that's not what you get it for I
just thought that it was taken out of
context and it wasn't sent refined on
you believing in your own opinions
although you said aye aye aye I think
that it went from there to kids
shouldn't go to college and it happened
so fast that you didn't really get a
chance to explain it in Full Tilt and it
was taken out of con and by the way and
by the way that's on me because guess
what I've had time now to create clarity
on my college point of view right yeah
that if you're an entrepreneur and
you're if your parents aren't paying for
it and you're gonna collect 150,000 in
debt like hey please pay attention
you're gonna come out of the system by
the way do you know many people instead
of buying a home and putting 333
thousand or 330 thousand on a home put
it into a stock or put it into Bitcoin
and it collapsed you know so this is
this is about self-awareness my my
biggest problem or let me phrase the
thing that's driving me is even a
clarification within it which is the
following and you know this better than
I do
I've just been doing a lot of homework
for the last five years we have a
culture where people maximize their down
payment on a home we live in a world
where it is stunning to me how many
people almost liquidate their entire
bank account for that down payment so to
me if you really like here in a
thoughtful discussion the amount of
people that I wish if they had two
hundred thousand right instead of them
you know buying a million dollar home
buying a half a million dollar home so
they can put a hundo down and then on
the other hundo do their side hustle or
some of the things that I'm passionate
if they're an entrepreneur if they think
they or a good investor or the think
they could do other things with money
but the reality is there's a lot of
people that should be doing that I'm an
extreme entrepreneur I there's a reason
I don't have safe investments in Wall
Street bonds in real estate it's because
I want to be on the offense it makes me
happy then there's people in the other
way who will do nothing on offense but
the reality is you know this it's funny
my original seed for this is people are
putting themselves in such vulnerable
spots because they're giving themselves
no flexibility because they're
maximizing the down payment to buy the
biggest possible house they can buy
record it and it's happening on an
everyday basis I know and that's what
you know that's what the collapse is and
so what I think what I think is I think
the industry needs more conversations
that aren't the status quo which is I
did a poor job and didn't create enough
sex and clarity and so I'm gonna deal
with the pain of that but the industry
as a whole could use a whole lot more
[ __ ] thoughtful conversations yeah
well maybe we'll do it on the deep dive
maybe I can't wait to see you bro I'm
really glad I got to reach out I
appreciate your time and when you decide
to get into the real estate space just
make sure you got a brother
take care later let's post it
everybody recorded that because I wanted
to hit it you know the meta nature of my
recording now so I was able to have that
combo and create some clarity's on the
lack of context and context is
absolutely what I believe in and we've
scaled very quickly Andy and so we and
by the way I this is not even on the
team that's a that's a cop-out I'm
positive when I listen to the podcast on
my way to NBA all-star I just remember
the mood I was in when I'm in that mood
showmanship I'm leaving a sentence or
two out that puts me in a vulnerable
spot and it happens in a lot of areas
and I've got to be better